loslegen kommt aus ihren verstecken und
schlag den ball gut laufen ja ein aufruf
an alle holen draußen das ist gut dann
habe ich eine menge feuerstein und
daraus kann man die menge leben machen
da muss ich jetzt gar nicht auf leben
sieht dienen mach es einfach mit dem
mini um stein mache ich ja mit dem
häuschen ich möchte die brics an rand
machen
dafür braucht man leben da brauche ich
zwei ziegel und antike lauda
babbel impuls kopple input als nur noch
123 elektronische dorfplatz stehen die
blätter beim stehen
das hab ich gedacht dass ich gedacht
leute hat er sich sparen dachte es wird
gedacht hat heute irgendwie so gar nicht
weiter haben wir wieder an zu dessen
geistlichen dass die fläche eignet wie
so lacht er wieso ist der junge fröhlich
drauf los die hooligans kommt aus euren
verstecken schlag diese rolle gut lauf
ist ja ein aufruf an alle hole geht's
dann draußen dann mache ich den intakten
die höhe
wenn ich doch da ist einfach noch einen
low voltage in pakistan eigentlich
doppelt so viel energie die reinkommen
sollte so sein ja okay gut aber verdammt
teuer also nicht sein dass man ab sagt
ganz hier kommt dann der mangel hin bis
ersten duell aber sagten hier könnte mal
ein tolles stand auf einmal kommen immer
eine gardine entgegen
natürlich sagt das kommt natürlich hier
einen player trachtet da hier gar nicht
weiter so genau wer hier bei ihrem tag
einfach ein loser couples nord
abgestiegen die brauchen wir verschenken
oder den manchmal auch noch in dieser
folge und meister soll ich werde ab
jetzt nicht mehr schlafen gehen ja ist
egal ich bin hier im hausbau und nutze
hause weil ich muss ja nachts jetzt
monster also freunde planen wenn einige
jetzt gerade neu dazustoßen oder so mein
plan für die nächste zeit ist erstmal
flexit fahren hier habe ich ja schon die
so ein bisschen pflegen damit er dann
links raus kommt ganz viel strings womit
ich mir dann ein kleines berg machen
kann also ein rucksack dann wird mein
haus bau fertig gemacht dann werde ich
mir in den mit dem scanner so ein
bisschen rumlaufen also
meining thriller the diamond drill und
bei welchen hast du davon mining trick
gibt es gar nicht oder doch gibt es
neben den drei mittel macht mir deine
diamond spitzhacke und plus mit
dolmetscher auf ihr zusammen und hält
unendlich den versuche ich dann auch zu
verzaubern in die mitte fische ziehen so
was muss ich muss ich schauen wie ich
das mache dann wollte ich mir eventuell
bald auch neue medium stein machen
einfach wenn der eine halle ist mit neun
und hat noch ein paar andere sachen also
kleinere sachen nicht jetzt als kleinere
die ich jetzt alle so fertig machen
möchte und dann kommen wir irgendwann
zur nano suit womit wir dann in aber
schwimmen cölbe glaube ich hoffe ich
also neben einer nicht man brauche die
komplette richtung aber ich werde mich
auf jeden fall jemand an die nachrüstung
setzen
und ja das wird noch ein langer weg
ein guter start informiert hastig wie
gesagt stell aber schon mal alles so hin
wie ich brauche das heißt was wirklich
leider nicht nur noch den mini um stein
fahren und dann geht's ab
jetzt habe ich 20 cent die brics nur
willst du das mal reinziehen die
konstruktion ist eigentlich recht klein
muss ich sagen was denn konstruktion wie
aus kabel reisen wird ja ich komme auch
über da warte ich mal kurz dir die paar
35 jährige ich habe euch kurz sagt das
nehme ich einfach mal an und dann wollen
ihr seht es wird was hier wird sehr
farbenfroh hinaus habe ich auch langsam
mal anfangen zu ackern also wer sonst
wird ihr echt nichts mehr raus also ich
meine jetzt aus technisch ja ja das wird
was hier aber ich brauche sehr sehr sehr
sehr viel leben das sehr viel
feuersteine dh sehr viel kies und kies
kann man sich doch aus cobbelsdorf
machen
über möchtest du nach strom aus dem kopf
außerdem ist auch ein minimum stein
seiner mini um das sagt jeder falsch so
europa und nicht körper wie kann man ja
durchlaufen
er guckt hier sage hierzu ich kabel rein
der geht dann hier oben wird zu
feuerstein das funktioniert auch schon
das halten eines transport kabel as sohn
war was bringt dieses ding im hölzernes
transport kabel das saugt raus das ist
die redstone engine die ist zwar sehr
langsam
aber die funktioniert nur mit redstone
das heißt ich muss keine energie
verbrauchen und wir haben ja zeit
oder sollten hier die kiste hinter als
nächster die goldene peitsche ist
eigentlich die verschmälert das bräuchte
man eigentlich zur schönheit gemacht und
es kommen natürlich auch kein eisen
auswahl bisher staut sich halt schauen
sich die feuersteine hier oben in der
mittleren weil da müsst ihr jetzt
minimum stein rein
beim mini um stein und dann geht er
weiter dass mein leben aufgenommen ja
aus versehen was lernt daraus gemacht
hier
ich weiß nicht wie ich das gemacht habt
ich hab die wörter die 4
die sind nicht mehr den momentan
glücklicherweise habe jeder vier
rausgekriegt so das muss nicht so
bleiben das rezept muss man einmal drin
sagt nimmt es einfach alles hier fehlt
übrigens mini um stein beim bei dem
freilich braucht noch zwei mini um
steine
ich war noch vier millionen steine das
heißt ich brauche 8 x 4 macht 2030 so
was wollte ich mir aufbauen
das habe ich noch 29 4 im freibad ist
die transport kabel aktivieren oder
irgendwie sowas ja genau deswegen ist
die red stage und dahinter das ist genau
das ist ja es gibt einmal mit wert von
einmal durchkämpfen mit der energie
machen dass ich das umwandler aber das
will ich nicht wollte dass so dass es
unabhängig davon läuft es einfach gar
nichts also bei jeder holztransport die
saugteil die goldene schneller mit der
diamond kanzler und erscheint sagen das
sei okay ärzte sollen da lang fließen
kabel dalla ist cool
also was soll ich auch machen bei mir
jetzt nur daran gehabt dass sie das
nicht umsetzen konnte ich wusste gar
nicht dass ich die transporte auch
allerdings muss hier aktivieren also mit
energie und seinen kampf das wusste ich
nicht das war mein problem daran lag hat
dann wahrscheinlich ist er sehr gut
so fließen dass daraus wirklich so viele
mini um steine auf das ist ja echt
uncool alter hatte wie kriege ich jetzt
viel macht hat sich sonst noch so
braucht
ok ich glaube das lohnt sich im
endeffekt schon ich bin wieder bei
meiner dingsda bei meiner quarry und
habe hier jetzt in einem ritt und ich
hab nie vor 5 minuten abschalten von
zehn minuten und ich habe ca 20 6 kabel
dass fünf eisen werden
ich brauche teams
die menge hieß
er kann ich nicht wenn ich irgendwie
kobil in irgendwie wird dreien tue es
gedacht es wird nach saigon und schwert
naja kommt raus achso und die fragmente
am nächsten samstag ist manchmal das
nano schwert fertig jetzt erst mal
gemerkt ich mache meinen ganzen
pflasterstein jetzt einfach zusammen
daraus machen wir dann einfach
feuersteine
ich habe wieder eine tastatur trophäe
gewonnen heißt katja ich hab von meiner
tastatur und der maus das ist ja
irgendwie so noch eine gewisse klick
anzahl erreicht oder gewiss schnell
klickt dann zur congratulations you
wanna trophy wo steht das dann minecraft
nur das ist von meiner maus oder
tastatur wenn der sachverhalt so geil
alter mdk nein ich brauche ich muss
jetzt stand in richtung wüste messe.de
am besten mit dem gleis stand
ich habe aber cash habe ich dabei und
sagen
das ding ist einfach nur ich weiß gar
nicht was drop überhaupt minimum
scherbel
drop nur monster das auch oder auch
normale figur wie war schon mal die
monster genannt papa doc ein glatter
sandstein das gut kann ich mir hier aus
wieder feuerstein machen mit das stimmt
was kann man denn aus glattem sandstein
machen
feuerstein würde ich dich gut
das heißt man kann vier sand zu zwei
feuerstein mal richtig das heißt es muss
ich auch noch ein wunder mich mehr
business geht neu krüger wollte doch den
mini um stein ab
komm ran ihr so sieben leben die lehm
wieder da rein geschrieben
das junge frisch staub frage ist halt
nur wie häufig machen wegpunkt ob sie
die homberger das stört mich viel zu
sehr
löschen ich mache hier hin hier jetzt
schon so 10 monster gekillt und keiner
hat mini umsteigen job und ich brauche
noch 29 stück ich glaube ich schaue mal
kurz bei fiete wies china was mich
danach gucken ja wir wärmen besten mini
um steine dropped mini um stein macht
dir doch einfach ein
die mini um später ich war 29 später
damit ich mir drauf minimum sherbiny ums
erbe wird am besten wird von ich habe
noch 5
wie im chart hit all i dropped off kill
player and does not have a 100 prozent
job sind auch schon oft dass die
hundertprozentig ist job bei aggressiv
mops wind kommt wein also als ich sie
wie mops attacke das war es schon
sie muss ja wann und schnetzeln da steht
das hat keine hundertprozentige job
chance mit sagen hat man ihm eine
zehnprozentige job chance wie sie
ausschaut ist sehr selten einmal getoppt
perfekt 28 optimistisch stimmen
diese werden im moment will das wird
meistens mehr als ich glaube es gibt
auch so was wie minimums den fans war
eine machtvolle baum muss praktisch war
es ja dann schon jetzt auch nichts
ist ja auch schon 30 minuten geknackt
wieder fast 27
das regt mich echt auf
ach so unschön wenn es dunkel ist dann
sehe ich hier die leuchtenden bienen
eismann ich muss richtig viel leben
jetzt halt einfach haben
ich glaube ich gehe doch gleich los in
zug leben wieder ein geländefahrzeug
einem mops war ihr schnee ist schnell
weg mit dir was ist das ja wohl davon
nennt muss ich auch noch einmal dahin
war der vulkan als läuft echt gut muss
man sagen
hast du jetzt mini um scherben
ich habe angekommen
mitten im wald und ich bin gerade läuft
dessen dingsda dass man nicht geplündert
wurde
also wenn du willst können wir jetzt
doch schon schlafen alles fertig ist
dann wird es so nichts ich mache mir so
viel mühe mit dem ganzen leben sachen
und finde ich einfach mal eben
alter ist das café moskau
das geht doch gar nicht ich mache mir so
viel mühe den ganzen leben dazu kriegen
und jetzt ist ja einfach mal richtig
viel leben unter wasser einfach aber
richtig und normal viel man ich bin
nicht so doof
richtig wie eisen gerade dieser tour
wie viele mops ist doch so ein von
diesem ruin mode da sind ja richtig
viele links da gerade hier also diese
ruinen also ja vom ruin mode ja so viele
mops bonner denn wenn es tag während
sporen die daher auch sein theoretisch
kann es ja fast schon wurst sein so da
vorne ist holmes wie tony blair war okay
und ich brauche mehr monster
ich brauch weniger monster töten hilfe
mich ja doch ich brauche doch schon
monster ich muss einfach so wenig der
shader ist so fährt dann dunkel
ich hab ja ein mops bonner gefunden aber
ich weiß nicht ob ich dann noch mal
wieder finde dass kein weg gemacht
eigentlich schade eigentlich müsste ich
wissen so dreckig gefragt dein weg punkt
gemacht